>>> I'M WITH HER JUST DIDN'T
MAKE ME FEEL AS A GUY THAT
DIDN'T GET TO SEE MY DAD ALL THE
TIME LIKE A GUY THAT COULD PLAY
CATCH WITH HIS SON.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT WHEN I
PUT THIS HAT ON, IT MADE ME FEEL
LIKE SUPERMAN.
THIS HAT, IT GIVES ME POWER IN A
WAY.
>> I AM WITH HER.
DIDN'T HILLARY CLINTON THINK
THAT THAT PHRASE MIGHT ALIENATE
A LARGE PART OF THE POM
A LARGE PART OF THE POPULATION.
IT TOOK SOMEONE LIKE KANYE WEST
TO PUT A BRIGHT RED HAT ON AND
SAY, HEY, WHAT ABOUT US?
HERE HE IS BACK IN AUGUST
EXPLAINING WHY THE MEGAHAT
REPRESENTS A LOT MORE THAN JUST
SUPPORTING TRUMP.
>> IT REPRESENTED OVERCOMING
FEAR AND DOING WHAT YOU FELT NO
MATTER WHAT ANYONE SAID.
THE HIP-HOP COMMUNITY CAN'T
BULLY ME.
AT THAT POINT, IF I'M AFRAID TO
BE ME, I'M NO LONGER YOU.
>> JOINING ME IS HOST OF TUCKER
CARLSON AND AUTHOR OF "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" NUMBER ONE BEST
SELLER, "THE SHIP OF FOOLS" THAT
JUST KNOCKED BOB WOODWARD OFF
THE NUMBER ONE SPOT ON "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER LIST.
TUCKER, FIRST OF ALL, I'M SO
HAPPY I KNOW YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, THANK YOU,
LAURA.
>> Laura: WHEN I WAS GOING
THROUGH SOME TOUGH TIMES, YOU
WERE ONE OF THE FIRST TO REACH
OUT TO ME.
PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW THIS ABOUT
TUCK YOUR, YOU ARE A REALLY GOOD
PERSON.
>> WELL, I'M NOT A GOOD PERSON
BUT I HAVE DEEP SYMPATHY FOR
ANYBODY, INCLUDING KANYE WEST,
WHO I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT.
I FEEL FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ALL OF
THE SUDDEN GETTING IT FROM
EVERYBODY.
>> I SAW YOUR SHOW LAST NIGHT
WHERE YOU TALKED ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF FATHERS AND MISSING FATHERS
AND ENTIRE SEGMENTS OF AMERICA.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT.
LOOK, HE IS NOT A POLITICAL
PERSON.
HE IS NOT GOING TO SPEAK IN
PUNDIT TERMS.
HE IS GOING TO SPEAK THE WAY HE
IS GOING TO SPEAK.
IT IS NOT MY MUSIC OR MY THING
NOR IS IT YOURS.
THAT WAS AN INTERESTING MOMENT
WHERE HE SAID THE MASCULINE
PRESENCE IN A FAMILY IS SO
IMPORTANT AND SHE DIDN'T SPEAK
TO ME.
IT WASN'T BECAUSE SHE WAS A
WOMAN.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF HOW SHE WAS
PORTRAYING HER CAMPAIGN.
>> HE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
ANTI-MASCULINITY.
THEY ARE ANTI-FATHER.
THEY HAVE TO BE.
THAT'S THEIR BASE.
THAT IS JUST TRUE.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
NOT EVERYONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BUT THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
PARTY IS.
ASK A LEADING DEMOCRAT.
IT IS REALLY SIMPLE.
I HAVE DONE IT.
IS IT BETTER, ALL THINGS BEING
EQUAL, IS IT BETTER FOR KIDS TO
GROW UP WITH THE DAD AT HOME?
THEY WON'T SAY IT, EVEN THOUGH
IT IS TRUE.
I GREW UP FOR PART OF MY
CHILDHOOD IN A SINGLE PARENT
HOME.
IT WAS GREAT.
I AM NOT ATTACKING ANYBODY.
IF YOU CAN'T SAY THAT, YOU ARE
LYING.
EVERYONE KNOWS YOU ARE LYING.
HE KIND OF CALLS THEM OUT IN HIS
STREAM OF CONSCIOUSNESS WAY.
WE SHOULD NOT ATTACK HIM FOR
THAT.
>> DAVID GERGEN , ONE OF YOUR
CLOSE FRIENDS ON CNN YESTERDAY
SAID THE FOLLOWING.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IS THAT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
SOME OF THE MEN IN THIS COUNTRY
AND THEIR RELATIONSHIP TO TRUMP?
IS BEING FOR TRUMP MAKE THEM
FEEL MORE MASCULINE?
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
BOY, THERE WAS SURE AN OVERTONE
OF IT IN THAT SESSION.
>> Laura: IN OTHER WORDS, THE
TOXIC MASCULINITY, IT IS A
BRUTAL TYPE OF BEING MASCULINE
TO BE IN LINE WITH TRUMP.
>> DAVIS DOING THE BEST HE CAN.
I AM NOT GOING TO ATTACK HIM.
>> Laura: WHY NOT.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR HIM.
THAT'S REAL.
MEN FEEL THAT THEY CAN'T BE MEN
AND THAT'S NOT A TALKING POINT.
I'M NOT A MEN'S MOVEMENT GUY OR
WHATEVER.
IF YOU HAD A MOVEMENT THAT WAS
AGAINST TOXIC FEMININITY OR
HOMOSEXUALITY, YOU WOULD SAY YOU
ARE ATTACKING PEOPLE FOR WHO
THEY ARE, BECAUSE IT IS MEAN AND
IT HURTS KIDS WHEN YOU DO THAT.
WE SEND $60,000 A YEAR THAT HAVE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENTS DEVOTED FOR
ATTACKING MEN FOR BEING MEN.
IF YOU HAVE A SON, THIS IS A
HUGE THREAT TO HIM.
IF YOU HAVE A DAUGHTER, WHO IS
SHE GOING TO MARRY?
THESE ARE CENTRAL QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: THE INTEREST THING
ABOUT TUCKER'S BOOK, IT IS SUCH
A GREAT READ.
IN YOUR "SHIP OF FOOLS" IS
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND MITCH
McCONNELL.
BOTH OF THEM WERE CRITICAL TO
PUSHING KAVANAUGH OVER.
>> THEY DID A GREAT JOB THIS
WEEK.
ANYBODY WHO BELIEVES IN FAIRNESS
SHOULD BE GRATEFUL TO THEM.
I AM.
>> Laura: WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
WALL YET, TUCKER.
>> WHICH IS NOT A SMALL THING.
BY THE WAY, WHEN REPUBLICANS
FACE DIFFICULTY IN THE
MID-TERMS, MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE
THE PARTY RAN ON BUILDING A
WALL, NOT ON AN ABSTRACT WALL
BUT ON A PHYSICAL WALL AND THEN
THEY SORT OF GIVE THE FINGER TO
THEIR VOTERS, WELL, THE WALL IS
KIND OF STUPID.
>> MAYBE IT IS STUPID.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF YOU TELL ME I'M GETTING A
PONY FOR CHRISTMAS, YOU BETTER
NOT GIVE ME A BAG OF HAIR.
I'M GOING TO BE REALLY
DISAPPOINTED.
>> Laura: I GOT A BAG OF HAIR
ONCE.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR DAILY LIFE.
YOU WAKE UP.
GIVE ME YOUR TIME.
IF YOU HAD TO JUST DROP INTO
TUCKER CARLSON'S LIFE, WHEN YOU
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING, IT IS
APPROXIMATELY WHAT TIME?
>> I WAKE UP AROUND 7:30 OR
8:00.
>> WHAT'S THE FIRST THING YOU
DO?
>> MY WIFE WAKES UP WITH A CUP
OF COFFEE AND I SIT AND DO
E-MAIL AND TALK TO HER FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS.
I TRY TO DO ALL MY WORK SITTING
IN BED.
>> Laura: LIKE CHURCHILL.
>> I WORK AND TALK TO A MILLION
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
I DON'T GO TO LUNCH.
I TYPICALLY GO INTO WORK AND DO
A TON OF WRITING AND THE SHOW
ENDS AND I GO OUT TO DINNER WITH
MY BELOVED NEPHEW TONIGHT.
>> Laura: HOW MANY DOGS ARE IN
BED WITH YOU?
>> TWO SPANIELS, MEG AND DAVE?
>> ARE THEY AT THE TOP OF THE
BED?
>> ALL FOUR OF OUR KIDS HAVE
GONE.
WE ARE THE PAIRTY OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THEIR
SPANIELS.
ONE I THINK THAT IS BASICALLY
MINE.
THE SMALLER SPANIEL, THE SUB
SPANIEL IS MORE LOYAL TO HER.
>> Laura: ARE THEY HUNTING DOGS?
>> BOTH ARE BIRD DOGS.
>> Laura: PHEASANT, QUAIL?
>> PHEASANT, QUAIL.
I GO SHOOT PIGS ONCE IN A WHILE.
I GREW UP BIRD HUNTING.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT A TENNIS
BALL?
>> THEY WILL TAKE A TENNIS BALL.
>> Laura: I AM SO HAPPY FOR YOU.
TUCKER IS ONE OF --
>> NOBODY HAS EVER ASKED ME
THAT.
>> Laura: TUCKER CARLSON "SHIP
OF FOOLS," GET THIS BOOK.
IT IS PHENOMENAL.
IT TRAILS THE ELITES ON THE LEFT
AND RIGHT AND PEOPLE TOOK IT AND
SAID, WE ARE GOING TO GO IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL YOU COME ON MY SHOW NEXT
WEEK?
>> DONE.
>> Laura: CAN I COME ON YOUR
SHOW NEXT WEEK?